academic so you know my I figured my job
and this was as a journalist was to tell
a story and tell it you know as
accurately as I could as thoroughly as I
could but also as entertainingly as I
could and I sort of I I tried to do that
I by I you know learning you know
luckily a lot of my my writing group are
novelists so they would they would tell
me you know we would exchange drafts and
read each other's work and you know they
would tell me if they would write in the
margins like god I am so bored or they
would they coined a term called
information dump like if I ingest you
know one that approved how much research
I did and just sort of like you know rue
page after page of statistics and
without any narrative thread throughout
they would call me on that and I was
really grateful for that it was
important for me to sort of get down all
the information but without losing any
narrative momentum so
you know it I didn't want to be
objective I wanted to have a point of
view and I hope I I hope the book does
have a point of view you know I think
that it's it's almost impossible for
anyone to be objective I think the whole
idea that journalists are objective is a
fallacy everybody comes to a story with
their preconceived ideas and
preconceived notions that's not to say
they can't change or be colored or
influenced or or broadened by what they
learn along the way but everybody comes
to what they went there about to write
with their own baggage to you know and
their research so I think that
objectivity is something that's really
not achievable and I don't necessarily